is it heartbreaking to you that
the uh so-called Donahue death squad
split or the team as it was originally
called split
you know we live a short life on this
Earth and you put so much of your love
and work into this team and everybody
put in the work does it break your heart
it was a sad time yeah it was
um it was uh
you know I'm not a particularly
emotional person
um but it was a it was an emotional time
for everyone it was I had an element of
tragedy insofar as Not only was it a
team breakup it was also a family
breakup which is much more serious
um
I do believe that in time uh
even the most intense family breakups
can be reconciled and I also believe
that once dialogue begins
people will remember
just how easy it was for us to get along
and how tight we were for many many
years
um it's so easy to let a minute of anger
destroy
10 years of of uh of friendship so
but there's also the weight of those 10
years like
um when I ran into the old Squad members
at ADCC we got along like a house on
fire it was like we never had a problem
um so a house on fire is a good thing
yes yes sorry that's a New Zealand
expression yeah
um uh yeah they definitely could have
gone the other way right
um so only in New Zealand I would say
that it's a good thing yeah
um so there's there's I I still believe
you know in in time things will be fine
but
um
there was an element where you know
youngsters need to grow and um uh
sometimes
think think about this way from The
Athlete's perspective
there's a definitely a generational
problem I'm much older than my students
okay and the the the years and the
Viewpoint that I have is a reflection of
the time in which I grew up
and uh they're from a completely
different generation with a completely
different world view
um it's it's got to be hard from The
Athlete's perspective when you're
training seven days a week and you
you're getting very very good you're
beating everyone that's getting getting
put in front of you you're losing very
very rarely and it's always a tough
competitive match when you do
everyone around you is calling you a
superstar
and you look phenomenal
you check social media everyone's saying
you're you're a God on the mat
and then you come into the gym there's
some old guy telling you you're not good
enough
and every day it's like oh what does
this guy want from me how how hard do I
have to work like you're not good enough
like I want you to be the best in the
world I want you to be good I want you
to be great
and all your friends are telling you all
that man you're incredible you submit me
so easily do this you and then this old
guys are saying that
you got to get better you got to work
more you're not working hard enough
at some point you got to be like you
know what [ __ ] this old guy
like it's it's tough you know mentioned
I I get why you know they lasted when I
was 20 years old I didn't get along with
authority figures at all and um uh to
have someone telling you you've always
got to work that little bit harder you
know your skill sets not complete you
still need distance and this when you're
already
doing very very well and far better than
all what a tiny tiny percentage of
people and then you've got this guy just
constantly telling you no more has to be
done you're not there yet
um I can you know of course I understand
you just want to let me just enjoy this
more like it's always a choice in life
do you you can be the best you possibly
can or you can
go around where you just get to enjoy
life a little more you do other things
you know like there's more of it to the
lights than just the inside of a gym and
learning how to do a better heel hook or
a better double leg
um so of course you know years go by you
want to try other things and
um uh you have to make this choice in
life between
extreme Excellence versus being
incredibly good but maybe just enjoying
my life a little more it's so
interesting that incredibly good is a
hard thing to deal with I saw like when
Kayla Harrison won her first gold medal
and uh the Olympics
you know to go back to the gym and to
trust again the maybe the old man you're
you're being do watching yourself but to
trust the old man so uh Jimmy Page on
Jimmy pager senior in that case to say
okay we're gonna go back to this grind
and they're still a path to Improvement
there's still a lot to grow and still
have the humility even though you've
just demonstrated greatness so really
good is just a stepping stone to to to
to to True greatness that's really tough
for athletes like winning is actually
very difficult gold medals are very
difficult plus there's the personal
stuff of depression that comes with that
which is you give so much of yourself to
trying to win that and once you do
there's a lot of personal stuff you have
to deal with which is like
what what uh what do I want from life
to understand what is exactly what am I
chasing is it just winning or is it some
bigger picture of Excellence that's
beyond just winning so that that's all
all that mixed up together and then when
you have to be as a team really close
together there's the personal
relationships all of that gets
exacerbated yeah do you think the team
ever gets back together
I think there's always you know there's
definitely a chance of that right now I
think they have a an excellent team
themselves and they're doing very well
uh they had an excellent performance at
ADCC so there's not a need for them to
uh to come to us because not like they
lack anything they still remember
everything I taught them they still
coach and teach with the same
methodology that I taught them so um I
don't think they have any need to do so
uh if they did it would because they
wanted to
um I still think many of the same
personality conflicts that originated
the conflict would re-emerge currently
if if they started training together uh
by the way to pile on the compliments
they have really nice merch too the
t-shirts are just excellent
um
what have you learned from that process
about how to have a team with personal
conflicts do you have to deal with these
giant egos as well yeah because ego is
in part of superpower too so you don't
want to yeah you you don't want to
suppress EOS I I always laugh when
people say leave your ego at the door
like what do you think drives
competition like if you want to be good
at anything in life you've got to have
an ego
um
uh no I don't believe it's good or even
a healthy thing to suppress egos
um I'm a realist and I understand that
this is a sport where they make one gold
medal per weight division this as guys
get better they're gonna be looking at
their training partners and thinking
like
I'm gonna have to fight this guy one day
and they're training next to each other
of course there's going to be tension
um there's always going to be uh
disagreements about you know what's the
right way to act around uh certain
people certain issues and people are
going to come into conflict everyone's
being programmed to be a an alpha
competitor and you get a room for a p
like that there's going to be conflict
now your question was well is there a
way to resolve this yeah there was and
for
eight to nine years I was very
successful with this but there's also a
Tipping Point where things can flare out
of control and there will be periodic
breakups you know you're not the first
students I had that that left I've been
coaching a lot longer they've been
coaching the squad and
um uh
I'm sure in the future there'll be other
students who leave me hey that's just
the nature of the Beast it's sad when it
happens but Life Goes On
uh like Bukowski said love is a fog that
Fades with the first uh daylight of
reality or something like that so you
even love is temporary uh